wir haben tolles wetter ich habe richtig
lust draußen im garten zu arbeiten und
da stehen jetzt auch einige wichtige
aufgaben an und in diesem video zeige
ich euch mal fast er jetzt im
gemüsegarten fällig ist damit wir
richtig gut in die neue gartensaison
starten können wenn es jetzt wärmer wird
und die tage länger werden dann nimmt
aber nicht nur das gemüse an fahrt auf
sondern auch das unkraut wir haben zum
glück relativ so ziemlich gar keine
probleme mit unkraut das ist jetzt das
einzige was ich hier gerade finde aber
wenn du in deinem garten hast dann
bleibt da hinterher und fangen jetzt
schon an zu hätten solange die pflanzen
noch klein sind weil das geht dann
täglich wähler wenn du noch keinen
knoblauch gepflanzt hast dann ist jetzt
ein toller zeitpunkt dafür
es gibt ja zwei zeitpunkten einmal im
oktober und september so haben wir
unseren knoblauch gepflanzt das heißt er
ist jetzt schon in der erde und einmal
jetzt märz ist auch ein toller platz
zeitpunkt wir haben aber letztes jahr
bei der ernte einige knollen übersehen
wie es aussieht so dass da jetzt überall
kleine knoblauch pflanzen austreiben da
wachsen jetzt aber ganz viele auf einmal
vielleicht so acht oder zehn stück auf
einem fleck so können die keine dicken
knollen ausbilden also das würde so
nicht funktionieren deswegen vereins
nicht jetzt und pflanzt die so dass jede
pflanze genug platz hat eine schöne
dicke knolle auszubilden generell auch
auf allen wegen wo er jetzt etwas neu
sein oder pflanzen wollt den mut zur
seite ziehen weil sich der boden viel
schneller erwärmt er ruhig der iso wir
den boden was im winter total toll ist
aber jetzt wo die ersten sonnenstrahlen
wieder auf den boden scheinen wollen wir
dass er sich schön erwärmen kann
deswegen entferne ich den jetzt zu den
auf dem weg dass er nicht im weg und
dann wenn wir da unsere grenzen ein
[Musik]
die linken sind in die erde gewandert
investmentpause jung knoblauch schmeckt
nämlich auch super lecker auch das grün
kann man essen von den frischen
knoblauch und jetzt aus dem er gekommen
ist eine tolle sache und die legten
haben die chance noch mal eine tolle
schöne knaller auszubilden wenn ihr
wissen wollt wie man knoblauch pflanzt
dazu habe ich auch mal ein video gemacht
dass verlinke ich euch gerne da oben und
unten in der video beschreibe und bei
den pflanzen die jetzt und auf euren
beeten wachsen da den will ich natürlich
nicht entfernen weil er eine gute
wärmeisolation ist also nur auf den
beeten uhr jetzt was aussehen wollte
aber die ihr auch schon gemacht habt
seht ihr wie stark das hochbeet abgesagt
ist ich habe da immer so ein bisschen in
zwiespalt weil ich einerseits da jetzt
schon super viel gesät und gepflanzt
habe weil sie ja das ganze jahr über
immer was auf unseren bieten drauf haben
und andererseits dieses hoch wie total
gerne auffallen würde dann aber alle
pflänzchen die jetzt hier drin wachsen
spinat mangold frühlingszwiebeln und so
weiter dann als nehmen müsste und
woanders hin pflanzen müsste oder danach
wieder hier rein kommst du musst das
wäre auf jeden fall ein großer aufwand
ich mach das jetzt mal davon abhängig ob
in den nächsten wochen ein kompost
lieferung bekommen oder nicht falls
nicht dann ist sie jetzt auch ein
bisschen egal ob es abgesagt ist aber
eigentlich ist jetzt ein guter zeitpunkt
bevor ihr neue pflanzen in eure besetzt
und die mal wieder richtig schön
aufzufüllen
im privat kasten ist der erste spinat
aufgegangen
der will natürlich immer noch fleißige
tasten werden messen nicht rein regnen
kann die ersten frühlingszwiebeln und
ersten triebe mangold haben sie hier
drin ganz wichtig dass wir jetzt nicht
vergessen hier unter ihrer haube dann
kann man jetzt auch ein paar gut raus
pflanzen es gibt so zwei große
pflanzzeit punkte fährt wenn einmal
jetzt so merz und dann wieder im august
wenn du jetzt eher band pflanzt im
frühjahr dann hast du im sommer
wahrscheinlich höchstens eine ganz
kleine ernte wenn du schon im august
gepflanzt hättest dann hättest du jetzt
im sommer schon eine etwas größere ernte
also der august ist ein bisschen ein
besserer pflanzt zeitpunkt aber wenn du
jetzt gerne als beim pflanzen wild ist
das eine super möglichkeit dafür kannst
du entweder ableger von deinen alten
erdbeerpflanzen wende schon welche hast
die machen ihr so franken an dem der
neue bändchen wachsen oder du kaufst dir
einfach neue jungs tanzen auf dem
wochenmarkt
oder in der gärtnerei eine andere
wichtige aufgabe ist dass du aufpassen
muss dass deine pflänzchen nicht
erfrieren im moment ist es bei uns
nachts noch richtig kalt so bis minus 5
-7 grad und damit ich meine pflänzchen
die das vielleicht nicht so gut ab
können also der wilsing der jetzt
draußen steht und die dicken bohnen die
packen das aber die ganz kleinen spinat
glänzen die gerade erst aufgegangen sind
die murmel ich dann in ein vlies ein
nicht mehr als zwei lagen fließt auf
euren gemüsen aus bringen weil im winter
ist auch so eine sache
da fehlt oft das lichte oft ist die
kälte gar nicht so sehr das problem wie
das den pflanzen einfach licht fehlt und
wenn man dazu viele lagen fließt über
einander aus bringt dann haben die
pflanzen eben nicht mehr genug licht
also falls ich es einfach nur einmal
eine mittel- und dann leg ich es auf die
pflanzen drauf immer gut beschweren dass
es nicht wegfliegen kann und so sind die
dann auch vor den kühleren temperaturen
gut geschützt wachsen schneller gehen
schneller auch es ist also gerade jetzt
im jahr super wichtig dass man den
wetterbericht so ein bisschen im blick
hat merkt wann es wieder kühler wird und
dann auch mit dem aussehen und raus
pflanzen vielleicht noch wartet wenn ihr
die nächsten tagen so starke fröste
angekündigt sind bis es ein bisschen
wärmer ist generell es jetzt auch ein
toller zeitpunkt um neue beete anzulegen
es kommt demnächst auch ein video zum
thema beete bau und also kasten beete
bauen niedrige hochbeete bauen also boni
gern den kanal und drückt auch die
glocke damit du das nicht verpasst wenn
dich das interessiert ja ich sage immer
eigentlich kann man rund ums jahr beete
anlegen
gerade nach der kompost methode wie wir
das machen geht das wunderbar man kann
schon am ersten tag direkt rein selten
und rheins ganzen hat super wenig
probleme mit unkraut die beete sind
schon im ersten jahr super pflegeleicht
und super ertragreich vor allem auch auf
dauer das wenn man den neuen garten
anlegt ja bis sich der boden aufgebaut
hat muss man den so weit verbessert hat
dass die erträge auch richtig gut werden
dass es bei kompost bieten gleich sofort
der fall wenn ihr wissen wollt wie das
geht also wie wir diese kompost beete
anlegen dann schaue gerne mal unten in
der video beschreibung vorbei weil
dadurch einen link für dich zum
gemüsegarten bootcamp das ist ein
kostenloser gemüsegarten mini kurs den
ich für euch erstellt habe und da zeige
ich euch ganz genauso ihr die kompost
biete anlegt wenn ihr den rhabarber in
ihrem garten habt und der jetzt schon
die ersten spitzen aus der erde steckt
dann könnt ihr den jetzt vor treiben
zuerst mal ein bisschen kompost und
vielleicht auch milch um den rhabarber
herum verteilen weil das dann nach und
nach verrottet und dem noch ein bisschen
wärme gibt unter seiner haube und dann
einfach ein maurer kübel oder ein eimer
es gibt auch so extraklasse mit dem man
die abdecken kann dabei es braucht man
anzubieten über den drüber stellten sie
das verdunkeln ist und dann treibt er
richtig schnell aus also das dauert dann
manchmal nur noch vier wochen bis man
den ernten kann
und das ganze geht viel schneller
obstbaumschnitt und beerensträucher
schneiden stehen jetzt auch an zum thema
johannisbeeren und stachelbeeren habe
ich ja schon videos gemacht die ihr
unten in der video beschreibung findet
ich kann ich auch da oben in die
infokarte packen
ich weiß nicht ob der stachel bei video
schon online ist weil ich das auch heute
filme aber falls es jetzt noch nicht
online ist verlinkt ich euch dass hinter
dem video sobald das online gegangen ist
wenn ihr kartoffeln anbauen wollt dann
gibt's jetzt auch eine wichtige sache zu
erledigen und zwar es ist total sinnvoll
die kartoffeln jetzt vor zu kommen so
dass sie wenn man sie dann im april oder
mai raus pflanzt einen
wachstumsvorsprung haben
dafür kann man die einfach aus
eierkartons legen das finde ich am
praktischsten und dann schön auf die
fensterbank in den eher kühlen raum
stellen aber so dass sie ganz viel licht
bekommen das ist ganz wichtig weil wenn
die dunkle stehen antreiben die ja auch
manchmal aus aber dann haben die so ganz
weiße längliche schwächliche triebe und
wir wollen dass sie richtig schön
gedrungene grüne oder lila je nach sorte
triebe haben die richtig schön kräftig
und dick sind das sind die triebe die
wir wollen damit werden wir die
kartoffeln dann aus pflanzen sie daraus
ganz schnell austreiben können und dann
mehr zeit haben um im beet richtig schön
dicke knollen zu bilden
ich weiß nicht ob es manchen von euch
vielleicht ähnlich geht mein freund ist
nicht so der leidenschaftliche gärtner
und er kriegt immer total die krise wenn
ich im frühjahr dann mein ans regal
auspacke und regelmäßig die ganze
wohnung voller erde ist und der hat
gesagt die kartoffeln werden nicht mehr
bei uns zu hause vor gekannt deswegen
bin ich jetzt im wurzelwerk büro und
macht es hier das ist im moment sowieso
fast nie genutzt weil wir alle im home
office arbeiten und deswegen habe ich
jetzt hier meine riesen kartoffel aktion
gestartet ich habe noch längst nicht
alle kartoffeln alles gelegt aber ich
hoffe das stört niemanden übrigens
einige von euch sind ja einen
gemüsegarten staaten mit dabei und
schaut mal was da hinter mir an der wand
hängt das sind bilder von euch die uns
geschickt hat von ihren wunderschönen
gärten das kann also gut sein dass dein
bild da oben bei uns an die romantik
wenn du im gemüsegarten start mit dabei
ist weil es gibt nichts was uns so
motiviert wie von der arbeit auf zu
schauen und zu sehen warum wir das
machen das ist so toll ist dass so viele
leute da draußen anfangen zu gertmann so
unglaublich wunderschöne prachtvolle
gemüsegarten anlegen und das wir euch
dabei helfen können ist unglaublich also
ich weiß gar nicht so ganz genau wie es
formulieren soll aber je mehr leute
rausgehen und ihr eigenes essen anbauen
und wieder einen bezug zur natur
herstellen und ihren kindern mitgeben
können was es heißt lebensmittel
anzubauen und wo die herkommen und dass
die einen extrem hohen wert haben den
wert den man gar nicht am supermarkt
preis ablesen kann
das finde ich so genial dass wir ein
teil davon sein können so viele leute zu
inspirieren rauszugehen und loszulegen
ist unglaublich also dankeschön letztens
hat der rekord ii ein video gemacht wo
er erzählt hat dass er jetzt vollzeit
youtube macht wegen die hat mich dass
auch total bewegt weil ich finde dass
ist so unglaublich dass wir die
möglichkeit haben sowas zu machen so
viele leute zu erreichen und sie
inspirieren
das ist der hammer also je mehr ich
darüber nachdenke desto unglaublicher
finde ich das und danke schön dass ich
das machen darfst unglaublich ja hier
sitzt nur ein normaler weise immerhin
schaut euch zu weil wir da oben an der
wand
ja ich war mir so wieder im boot zu sein
schon schwierig im hauptlauf ist oder
aber kommen wir zurück zu den kartoffeln
ich habe total lust mal zu zeigen wie
man kartoffeln oder umgraben anbauen
kann wie man ein nötig kartoffel bethan
legt also schreibt mir gerne mal falls
euch das interessiert weil
die kartoffeln fertig vorgekämpft sind
dann würde ich total gern so ein video
für euch machen und euch zeigen wie man
auch mit kartoffeln ganz neues beet
anlegen kann das ist super cool
bei uns fällt auf jeden fall im haus
gerade viel mehr arbeit an als draußen
weil die ganzen jungen fans ihren
vorgezogen werden wollen das macht mir
super viel spaß gerade wenn es draußen
noch ein bisschen regnerisch und diesig
ist und kalt dann drinnen im haus schon
mal anzufangen also schaut auf jeden
fall auch in dem märz aussagen video das
ich vor ein oder zwei wochen gemacht
habe vorbei so dass ihr wisst welche
pflanzen jetzt im haus vorziehen müsst
die hier können bald alle nach draußen
gepflanzt werden und deswegen hätte ich
dir jetzt abstellen sie nach draußen für
ein paar stunden heute dürfen sie zum
ersten mal nach zu hause und stellte sie
dann wieder nach tränen so dass sie sich
an die sonne und den wind gewöhnen
können und jetzt am anfang stehen sie
erst mal noch im schatten danach stelle
ich sie dann schon mal in zwei drei
tagen ein paar stunden am tag in die
sonne
dann kommen sie wieder in schatten dann
kommen sie wieder nach drinnen so dass
die jeden tag ein bisschen länger
draußen sind ein bisschen länger der
sonne ausgesetzt sind und dann nach
ungefähr einer woche sind sie so
abgehärtet dass sie nach draußen
umziehen können da drüben findest du
mein video zu haushalt im märz also wenn
du jetzt schon loslegen willst egal ob
im haus oder draußen dann kannst du dir
da anschauen was sie jetzt sehen und
pflanzen kannst ansonsten verlinkt ich
dir da auch mein gemüse garten boot camp
meinen kostenlosen mini kurs so dass
zuschauer und kannst wie wir die beete
anlegen und gut gewappnet bist für die
neue gartensaison